bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france angela merkel a déclaré elle même
en arrivant à bruxelles ce matin les
négociations s'annoncent très difficiles
à quoi est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
selon vous un énorme bras de fer entre
d'une part le couple franco allemand le
tandem franco-allemand je préfère le
tempo tandem que le mot couple et
d'autres pays qui soutiennent le tandem
franco-allemand je pense notamment à
l'espagne à l'italie avec les quatre
pays frugaux oupeye rada comme on veut
également ne pas oublier certains pays
d'europe centrale je pense notamment à
la pologne et plus encore la hongrie
donc je n'ai pas gagné et pourtant c'est
l'un des sommets les plus importants de
ces dernières années
emmanuel macron ce matin ce sommet sera
un moment de vérité pour l'europe et
c'est l'unité de lieu qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui c'est la volonté de loi de
tirer les leçons de la crise du coroner
virus mais surtout d'aller vers en avant
de vouloir mener une politique
courageuse et il faut quand même
souligner on l'a fait dans la presse
française n'a pas toujours fait dans
d'autres pays
l'énorme concessions que vient de faire
le gouvernement du berlin la chancelière
angela merkel d'actifs d'accepter la
mutualisation de la dette c'est un une
avancée extraordinaire et très marquante
de l'histoire dans l'ue de l'union
européenne c'est une étape décisive et
parce que c'est une étape décisive
et bien tout simplement il faut la
gagner alors en ce bas du mois de
juillet pour à cause du comique 19
nous sommes privés du tour de france
mais disons ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est un peu comparable avec une étable
type un peu d'huez
pourquoi est ce que le rôle que jouent
les pays dits frugaux et ils scrutent
haie de cyprès pour quelle raison on
parle tant de ces pays frigo parce que
ce sont des pays radin alors là je
reprendrai ce terme dans la mesure où
ces pays ne veulent pas partager les
dépenses ne veulent pas mutualiser la
dette et veulent préserver leur avantage
client si ce sont des pays très vite les
pays-bas la suède le danemark la suède
n'est pas membre de l'union européenne
et de la zone euro plus et l'autriche et
là il ya également un événement
important qu'on a peut souligner en
france c'est le désaccord entre angela
merkel et sebastian coates est à dire
entre la chancelière allemande
chrétienne démocrate et sebastian course
que chancelier autrichien chrétien
démocrate et il faut savoir que
normalement l'autriche suivait toujours
la politique allemande
et ce n'est pas le cas et encore si on
va un peu plus loin dans la politique
allemande latine sous bavaroise qui
était toujours très proche de l'autriche
de la position des chrétiens démocrates
autrichiens je dire qu'il y a des
chances de devenir prochain chancelier
de la république fédérale d'allemagne
soutien à la mère qu'elle contre
l'autriche
donc il faut encore souligner l'énorme
avancé l'énorme courage de la république
fédérale d'allemagne dans ces temps
difficiles et leur volonté européenne
alors que ce n'est pas la volonté la
volonté des quatre pays qui sont je le
répète des pays privilégiés et qu'ils ne
veulent pas véritablement mettre fin à
leurs privilèges
je reprendrai également là une
comparaison historique nous sommes à
quelques jours du 4 août ou 1 15 jours
du 4 août
ces quatre pays ils ne veulent pas vivre
une nuit du 4 août c'est clair et net
non on parle beaucoup de respect
politique de cette réunion mais il est
aussi question de ce plan de relance de
l'économie ce qu'il est vital pour les
économies nationales qu'est ce qu'ils
prévoient ce plan de relance de
rappelons-le 750 milliards d'euros alors
c'est un changement de logique jusqu'à
présent dans la crise notamment dans la
crise de l'euro la crise grecque le mot
c'était économies il faut couper
des vivres il faut véritablement mener
une politique d'austérité
c'était la politique qui a été défendue
notamment par un gain de la merkel de
2010 à 2015 2016
et là c'est pas du tout ça c'est on est
beaucoup plus dans une logique
interventionniste une sorte de new deal
européen
et si vous voulez on retrouve là deux
logiques économiques différentes
et la logique allemande qui était une
logique d'austérité est beaucoup plus
proche actuellement de la logique
française qui est une néophyte
d'intervention et de dead pour que
l'union européenne les membres de l'ue
en pleine puisse sortir plus ou moins
indemne de cette crise économique ima
est très grave merci beaucoup pour votre
regard gilbert casasus professeur en
études européennes